five at four
this is eight news now all right it has
hosted some of the biggest artists in
the world including some of my favorite
favorites alicia keys and lady gaga yeah
now the pearl theater inside the palms
ready to open once again reclaiming its
position as an artist and audience
favorite heather mills got an exclusive
look inside the iconic venue with the vp
of entertainment crystal robinson wesley
billy idol was actually the last person
to perform on the stage here at the
pearl theater inside the palms it's
getting ready to reopen and we're going
to take you backstage for your first
sneak peek follow me
what better way to do it with pat
benatar neil geraldo with a sold out
show uh yeah you have an inductee to the
rock and roll hall of fame on stage okay
let's let's see
wow absolutely
take a look at this it's beautiful fun
fact
no one's seat is more than 120 feet
from the stage what is the benefit of
coming to a show that is so intimate and
small all of the insulation the covers
on the seats what's happening with the
wall decor all of that plays into what
you hear in a theater like this that's
where the attention was right what is
the view for the person that's sitting
in the chair you know make sure there's
no obstructed views what do they hear
what do they see and then what do they
feel and all of that's going to come
into it to deliver a great experience
these are our vip skyboxes wow
yes so we have six on this side and six
directly across okay we've got dedicated
bar hospitality
places to lounge televisions as well as
dedicated restrooms so this is it this
is it
the iconic stage look at how intimate
this gets pretty impressive very much so
the magic before the magic yes happens
back in the dressing rooms this is one
of our larger dresser rooms that we have
here this is the spot nobody else is
going to see but the artist and well you
now so this wall shows pearl down
through the years it's a historical
representation of some of the great acts
that have performed on the stage all who
have residencies now here in town i mean
but this is where they perform it
doesn't get more up close and personal
or intimate as this
we're just getting started you know i
want to bring in shows that will attract
you know all ages residencies have
become such a popular thing for a lot of
the concert venues across town is it
something that you guys are looking at
are you hoping to just get one off we're
going to start off a little bit more
with the one-off approach it's not that
we will completely shy away from
residencies but we think the the sauce
the secret sauce for us will be in the
variety so there you have it your
backstage and on stage pass before the
pearl theater opens on saturday heather
mills 8 news now
very cool very cool now the pearl used
to host ufc fights robinson wesley says
they're looking into boxing as well you
can find a list of upcoming shows on the
palms website